molti bambini e ragazzi
ancora non possiedono le competenze
tecnologiche
stabili e raffrontare la loro vita da
adulti qualcuno potrebbe dire che è
tutta colpa della scuola che non fa
abbastanza qualcun altro potrebbe dire
che è tutta colpa dei genitori che gli
mettono fra le mani questi dispositivi
tecnologici e digitali e poi non mi
regolamentano la volete sapere la verità
in realtà non è colpa di nessuno non è
proprio colpa di nessuno ma
semplicemente tutto il fenomeno della
tecnologia e del digitale ha invaso le
nostre vite cogliendoci anche
impreparati
esattamente come fa un onda quando
invade la spiaggia di fatto tutto quello
che noi stiamo vivendo e conosciamo
delle tecnologie e del digitale fino a
qualche decennio fa neanche esisteva
eppure noi come società come persone
abbiamo ben capito nelle nostre vite
quali fossero i benefici nell'utilizzo
del digitale ad esempio lo utilizziamo
quando cuciniamo nelle nostre case per
divertirci per viaggiare per comunicare
immaginate immaginate in medicina grazie
alla tecnologia sono stati fatti dei
progressi grandissimi in ambito medico
esistono dei software di intelligenza
artificiale che permettono ai medici e
ai dottori di diagnosticare con assoluta
precisione molte malattie
esistono già dei visori di realtà
aumentata che i medici chirurghi possono
indossare nel mentre che stanno
compiendo la loro operazione loro
intervento in modo tale da poter vedere
sovrapposto sul corpo del loro paziente
ad esempio la lastra all atac in modo
tale da andare a operare con accurata
precisione
immaginate adesso le aziende dove la
tecnologia è stata correttamente
interpretata e dove è stata introdotta
la dove c'erano dei rischi effettivi per
le persone per il loro apparato muscolo
scheletrico per la loro vista per
l'olfatto per la loro vita in alcuni
casi la robotica ha permesso
a tanti lavoratori di migliorare la loro
vita lavorativa e tante aziende che
hanno abbracciato la digitalizzazione
adesso possono comunicare con qualsiasi
cliente in qualsiasi parte del mondo e
potenzialmente a qualsiasi ora e ora
pensate in quale scenario grandioso e
meraviglioso stiamo guidando i nostri
figli i nostri bambini ei nostri ragazzi
uno scenario in cui in virtù della
tecnologia loro potenzialmente potranno
essere degli uomini e delle donne più
libere perché questo è uno degli scopi
della tecnologia rendere più liberi dare
più tempo più spazio più sicurezza alle
persone
i nostri figli potenzialmente vivranno
una vita più longeva e più in salute e
vivranno un grandissimo potenziamento di
quelle che sono le loro azioni negli
ambiti di vita che loro sceglieranno
ogni loro azione
magari anche i loro pensieri
potenzialmente potrà essere ancora più
utile più efficace e più produttiva
naturalmente tutto questo se la
tecnologia sapranno farla fruttare a
loro favore
e se ci chiediamo quanto sia lontano
tutto questo dalla nostra realtà
beh è molto vicino lo stesso elon musk
considera da tanti uno dei profeti i
nostri tempi colui che ha creato paypal
che tutti noi conosciamo se si è o di
tesla motors ii o di spaces
lui dice che l'intera umanità fra cinque
e ho detto 55 anni vivrà grandissimi
cambiamenti tali per cui non saranno
neanche minimamente paragonabili a tutto
quello che abbiamo vissuto nelle nostre
vite degli ultimi 50 anni a livello di
progresso
e allora la domanda è questa
li stiamo preparando adeguatamente i
nostri bambini i nostri figli i nostri
ragazzi ad affrontare la loro vita del
futuro
ora vi spiego come stanno i fatti io
sono veronica rem ordina sono una pare
il coach professionista o laurea
quinquennale psicologia e con i miei
corsi di formazione per le aziende per
per i genitori nelle aule nelle scuole e
con i miei percorsi di coaching scende
in campo al fianco di tutti quei
genitori che vogliono fare semplicemente
di più o di meglio per i loro figli e in
particolar modo con i nostri percorsi
formativi con i progetti di vita
andiamo assieme ad individuare tutto
quello che conta è che è indispensabile
nell'educazione odierna e fra poco
andiamo a vedere quali sono alcuni di
questi aspetti fondamentali
ora mi rivolgo a voi genitori perché io
lo so che oggi non è semplice lo so che
a volte può essere anche non troppo
facile lo so perché sono madre anch'io
ma non si può delegare tutta la
questione importante relativa
all'educazione ad altre figure agli
insegnanti alla scuola pensando che
facciamo tutto loro ma come genitori
abbiamo il compito di spargere dei
semini nella mente nella testa dei
nostri figli dei nostri bambini dei
nostri ragazzi per fare in modo che un
giorno se loro vorranno potranno far
crescere questi semini potranno farli
fruttare a loro piacimento nella loro
vita in quello che loro sceglieranno di
fare come possiamo farlo tutti i giorni
potete ispirare con le vostre parole i
vostri comportamenti e le vostre azioni
i vostri figli lo potete fare anche
creando l'ambiente educativo più adatto
per loro e adesso andiamo a vedere
quelli che sono gli aspetti fondamentali
e immancabili dell'educazione di oggi
prima cosa non accontentatevi mai di
mettere fra le mani dei vostri figli dei
vostri bambini dei vostri ragazzi i
tablet e gli smartphone
errare che se la cavino perché questo
sta creando quelli che saranno i clienti
delle multinazionali di domani sta
creando dei tester su cui vengono
testati le app e i videogiochi più in
voga ma quello che dovete fare è
cambiare loro paradigma e fare di tutto
quindi affinché loro imparino il
linguaggio della programmazione il
linguaggio della programmazione sta
diventando il nuovo linguaggio
universale il linguaggio che permetterà
ai bambini ai ragazzi di oggi veramente
di cambiare la loro comprensione della
tecnologia e da semplici fruitori di
tecnologia loro potranno diventare dei
creatori se lo vorranno nelle loro vite
di tecnologia
sicuramente la potranno fare fruttare al
meglio e potranno controllarla meglio
secondo aspetto allenate il loro
pensiero flessibile questa una
competenza indispensabile oggi perché in
un contesto così mutevole come quello
odierno è indisponente è indispensabile
avere flessibilità di pensiero noi non
sappiamo se loan mask avrà ragione se
effettivamente ci saranno questi grandi
cambiamenti ma allenare pensiero
flessibile dei bambini dei ragazzi
permetterà indubbiamente di muoversi
meglio nel contesto in cui andranno
vivere gli permetterà di affrontare
nuove sfide e nuovi problemi di
raggiungere i loro risultati più ambite
terzo aspetto allenate quella che è la
loro soglia attentiva e di
concentrazione perché oggi lo sappiamo
viviamo nell'era della distrazione ma
c'è un fatto che pochi sanno è che i
nostri bambini ei nostri ragazzi di oggi
e non per una questione di evoluzione
hanno una soglia attentiva molto bassa
ma semplicemente perché sono sottoposti
ed esposti a continui stimoli a continue
stimolazioni allora come genitori
impegnatevi tutti i giorni a giocare con
loro nelle attività che più gli
piacciono o fate svolgete con loro delle
attività quelle che più
passio nano in modo tale da allenare la
loro soglia attentiva quarto punto
allenate il loro pensiero computazionale
questo una competenza importantissima
nel prossimo futuro
l'autrice janette wind nel 2006
definisce il pensiero computazionale
come la capacità di un individuo lo
sforzo di un individuo nella dare
istruzioni ad un altro individuo o ad
una macchina affinché essi possano
portare a termine un uno scopo
ecco questa è una competenza
fondamentale non solo perché in questo
contesto mutevole ci saranno molti
cambiamenti a livello di lavoro a
livello di procedure e quindi avere la
capacità la competenza proprio
sviluppata del livello computazionale li
aiuterà anche ad andare a formare le
altre persone ma noi oggi sappiamo che
quello del trainer di macchine ad
esempio è uno dei lavori che prenderà
piede nel futuro e se loro lo vorranno
avere questa capacità le aiuterà
tantissimo
dulcis in fondo soddisfate amorevolmente
e incondizionatamente tutti quelli che
sono i loro sogni i loro bisogni di
bambini ed i ragazzi perché più loro
sentiranno di esser soddisfatti nei loro
bisogni e meno andranno rifugiarsi nel
mondo del digitale per cercare di
soddisfarli e poi comunque ci sta che ci
vadano lo stesso per divertirsi
ludicamente o per intrattenersi ultima
riflessione
cento anni fa maria montessori ci ha
detto che l'educazione deve servire
all'uomo per permettergli di conoscere
l'ambiente circostante le risorse
dell'ambiente circostante
perché queste risorse dell'ambiente
circostante unite alle risorse delle
persone gli permettono di portare a
termine con soddisfazione i suoi compiti
gli permettono di raggiungere i suoi
obiettivi di essere più felici e oggi
l'ambiente circostante
e fatto di tecnologia e non possiamo più
nasconderla questa cosa quindi
sicuramente aiutare i nostri figli i
nostri ragazzi
ad interpretare meglio la tecnologia gli
permetterà di se lo vorranno un giorno
di controllarla di più creare tecnologia
ma sicuramente di farla fruttare a loro
vantaggio
[Applauso]